welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the mad titan who wouldn't want to
make titan mad
and this video we're breaking down
episode 5 of invincible
there's a lot of change ups from the
comics but also some cool callbacks in
easter eggs that i think are definitely
worth talking about
the ending of the entry also leaves a
lot of things up in the air
and it's a big deviation from the source
material now the episode itself pulls
heavily from issue 19 of the comics
however it expands far beyond what
happened in that to give us a far more
grounded look at titan
and exactly what he's fighting for you
may remember him as being the first
villain that invincible took down in
episode one
and whereas in the source material he
merely met up with mark and the two
decided to take down machine head
here it's a much more involved look at
his home life we're going to be breaking
it all down but
if you've been enjoying the coverage so
far then i'd massively appreciate the
thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to keep up
to date with our videos on the show
now we open with titan who is named
after one of the moons of saturn
this very much speaks to his power set
and the character is able to encase his
skin in stone
in the comics we learn that this is very
similar to the way that johnny storm
does
it but instead of saying flame on titan
says rockon
now in addition to this i feel that the
anti-hero is very similar to luke cage
and we watch as this almost invincible
man ascends through the ranks of
organized crime
at the expense of others the opening
action scene isn't anywhere to be seen
in the original work
and it leads to a skull splitting moment
that shows how brutal of a bad guy that
he could be
there's also a point where a thug shoots
at him and the bullet ricochets back
and kills him instantly i feel this is
very similar to the moment at the
beginning of iron man when tony's
escaping the cave
and he paints him out as completely
indestructible from here we jump back to
another returning figure
and after invincible busts up the bad
guy from the ending of the first episode
again
we watch as amber waits on the character
in the comics the pair had quite a
strained relationship because he
wouldn't reveal his secret
and this led to her constantly
questioning what he was really up to
he tries to make things right by
bringing her a japanese cheesecake
and i just want to point out a
correction from last time in episode 4
we said he likely bought the 800
chest but as many of you pointed out
mark probably flew internationally
in order to get it for a much cheaper
price though amber said he only went
across
town to get the cheesecake he could have
gone abroad as the guy can travel around
the planet in mere seconds
travel around stealing stuff which is
exactly what i would have done do boom
just
in and out now cut to titan exiting a
burning building that he's just set fire
to
and we see the homeowners angered over
him destroying their property
though he gives them money this very
much juxtaposes the following scene
in which we see marks saving people from
being crushed in their homes
the public love him and he also fights a
woman that i think
might be based on cheetah from dc but
i'm not 100 sure
although he's beloved it becomes clear
that the hero life is causing havoc on
his real one
and in addition to being late to meeting
amber he's also late to work and this
leads to him quitting
in the comics he actually walked out
mid-shift and he was worried that his
father wouldn't approve of him just
quitting his job
however the character did it anyway to
focus on being a hero
and nolan actually wasn't too bothered
about this which was the first clue he
got which hinted to him believing that
he was above humanity and
all their rules from here another
parallel scene happens
in which we see titan dangling a man
over the edge of a building by his leg
this is mirrored in mark and nolan who
do something similar with a super
villain
but whereas titan pulled the person in
they let him go
omniman shows a complete disregard for
human life and we don't actually see him
saving this person
though it's taken that he does however
this show cleverly cuts away from
revealing this
as in our minds it further paints him
out as someone who has a much darker
side to them
back at high school marcus stopped in
the corridor by principal winslow
who's voiced by reginald johnson aka
sergeant al powell from die hard be
careful there mark we all know how this
guy loves to shoot kids anyway
winslow himself does pop up throughout
the story and
some minor minor spoilers here that you
might want to skip ahead 30 seconds full
but
have you gone yet you don't carry
winslow actually becomes the dean of the
college that mark attends
so it's nice that they have a
conversation at this point about him
going to one because it sort of
foreshadows their future
spoilers over for that bit now titan's
reign of terror continues
i mean watch as he steals a microchip
and intimidates the security guards
into firing into the air so it looks
like they tried throughout the episode
titan spares several people
and though the ending teases that he's
going to be the big bad it does show
that he has a softer side to him
now turns out the device he's stealing
is for machine head a black mask-esque
villain who we learn in the comics
controls crime across the entire country
here it's scaled down to the city but
either way he's a very powerful
individual titan has been indebted to
the character
and has been acting as an enforcer in
order to settle his debts
but the autonomous auto-tuned android
has the plans
he threatens the character's family to
keep him working for him and we actually
see titan's home life
in the source material he merely meets
with invincible fills in what's going on
and the pair then fly off to machine
head's office
which is where the big fight plays out
that ends this entry
i love these closer looks at the
character as they carried with them a
lot more information
and really showed titan in a far more
complicated light
throughout the entry we discovered that
this microchip is actually a quantum
probability device
and in layman's terms this allows the
bearer to see all
eventual scenarios and outcomes from a
certain starting point
it runs complex simulations to make it a
fortune telling device
and this allows machine head to plan for
the attack at the end
which we'll talk about towards the final
part of the breakdown we jump to space
to see mark stopping an asteroid
and learn that at this moment he's meant
to be meeting amber's mother
amber is clearly frustrated by his
constant lateness
and just as he's about to tell her that
he's a superhuman he decides to bite his
tongue
on his walk home we see him kick a stone
which takes off the top of a roof
and this moment signifies that though he
wants to live a normal life
it's almost impossible his father calls
him to take part in some crime stopping
and it cements that this will always be
the direction that he's pulled towards
because of his abilities
he must sacrifice the things he loves in
order to be a hero
and this is murder in titan who returns
home to his family
his wife hates the fact that he's having
to sacrifice the things he loves in
order to be a villain
and the pair are really opposites of the
same coin titan is living on the
breadline
whereas due to nolan being a hero that
worked alongside the government
he's been funded to the point that his
family can live a comfortable life
titan is down in the gutter whereas mark
is on high and this is showcased in the
former and his daughter watching
invincible flying high with a villain
that we're just going to refer to as
elephant man now elephant man is of
course a play on the rhino
and he also appears in issue 8 of the
comics so it's nice that this scene gets
some lip service here
whatever way you look at it though
neither have the perfect home life
and we cut to debbie in her cupboard who
discovers damien darkhold's notebook
which is based on the necronomicon from
the evil dead we did the arise last time
that this might contain the means to
bring the dark detective back
but all it has are clues that send
deborah off on a path to discover her
husband's bloodied costume
this is a complete diversion from the
comics and they reveal that he was
behind the death of the guardians
completely blindsided her
when it was brought to the surface i
much prefer her actually having some
agency
and piecing together things on her own
as it shows how much omniman has lost
the trust of those around him
cut to atom eve who is two having issues
at home
and we see how her parents are angry
that she broke up with rex
because he cheated on her they worry
that she's not someone who can protect
herself
i would rather see her with someone that
basically treats her like crap
than on her own it really speaks to how
everyone undervalues her
and in the comics she reveals that she
doesn't even bother wearing a mask
because even in her personal life no one
sees her as anything more than an
average girl
however eve is actually one of the most
powerful people in all of the invincible
universe
and as she says she's able to rearrange
atoms on a molecular level
similar to skull at which the character
can alter almost
anything and she's frustrated over being
held back
later she meets mork and amber and after
he dives out the pair bond whilst
helping out with a homeless shelter
now this differs highly from the comics
as they never really had a moment like
this together
in fact the only real quality time that
the pair shared was in
issue 31 when mark and amber went to
meet eve at her home in africa
here eve talked to mark about how he and
amber would never really see eye to eye
because he was literally and
figuratively up in the clouds
while she was down on earth however due
to the many changeups here
you realize that eve has much more of a
respect for her and she clearly yearns
to experience the normality that she has
mark meets with titan and we learn the
inner workings of machine heads
operation
as well as his patna in crime isotope
who has the ability to teleport
mark has been focusing so much on the
high level crimes
he's completely overlooked all of this
and he sees that in order to be a true
hero
he can't just focus on the bigger
picture we discover that titan is using
mark
and this is initially pointed out by his
father who doesn't want him to help at
all
nolan again only cares about
participating in things that threaten
the world's security
and this very much speaks to how he's
willing to let the people on the planet
tear each other apart
as long as the planet itself is okay
people who've read the comics will know
exactly what this means
and if you want to learn more about
what's going on with the character then
check out our omniman explained video
debbie is clearly struggling seeing her
husband in this new light
and she says people aren't who they
appear to be this clearly suggests she
knows the truth about nolan
and she is the one who talks mark into
helping titan
at the guardian's headquarters we see a
scene that isn't in the comics
and actually sets up a lot of what's to
come the guardians are just chilling out
and
they clearly don't take things seriously
which annoys the original member black
samson quite a lot
he tells them that they fight as six
individuals rather than as a team
but this falls on deaf ears which bites
them in the butt later on
another change up is that monster girl
says she's 25
whereas in the source material she's 29
but
pointless dl but just thought i'd point
it out she also says that she's lost a
week
and in the comics we discovered that
every time she turned into a monster
she actually became younger whilst it
grew more and more grotesque
this inspired robot to help find a cure
for her which further led him to attempt
to enact his own plan
which we'll discuss later on he
eventually ends up recruiting the
maulers
cementing that they're skipping over the
bit about them resurrecting the immortal
and now going straight into the
storyline involving robot and the thing
we saw in the tank at the end of the
last episode
one thing to bear in mind here is that
the cloning process we see them all as
an acting
makes a complete duplicate of someone's
mind this means that the mind isn't
transferred it's not shifted across into
another body
and instead it's simply a copy this is
something robot wants to exploit and
throughout he shows a lot of humanity
towards monster girl
when she later gets badly beaten up it's
clear that he's in agony over it
and we see another side that solidifies
his objectives
now we discovered that the lizard league
were the people that they were fighting
against
and these are inspired by the captain
america villains the serpent society
this fight scene itself actually
appeared in issue 9 of the comics
where mark went head-to-head with them
saved by adam eve
i appreciate that they show the
incompetence of the new guardians
rather than just having it being
something that shows mark once more
because
let's face it we'll know quite a lot
about him already now cut across to
debbie and nolan arguing
and we learned that the former was very
much the one that instilled humanity
into him
it very much speaks to velcro my culture
that he had none of the kindness or
warmth that we've seen him display
until he met her we know there is a much
darker side to him
and you can sort of start to see the
pieces fall into place
as we learn more about them beltram was
a society that went planet to planet
throughout the galaxy
making them align with their ways nolan
said that they had achieved the height
of civilization
where there were no wars murders or any
crimes
they wanted to pass this order onto
every planet and as we know
nolan came to earth to try and instill
those values into us
however because of this he hadn't
experienced certain sides of humanity
and these two cultures are very much
embodied with a mark
debbie gets nolan out of the house
perhaps inspired by cecil
who last week tried to send him into
space so that they could investigate his
dealings whilst he was away
she gets him to fly to europe and
discovers the bloody clothes
implicating him further the episode
wraps up with a big battle between titan
invincible and machine head syndicate
amongst these are battle beast who in
the comics is described as the scourge
of twin galaxies
he's a master at combat and can travel
across twin galaxies i'm guessing now
we also have magnet attack krusk a
russian secret weapon with electricity
powers
furnace who we're told just looks cool
magmaniac
a living furnace and lastly the tenor
tyrant
who i feel is a play on doctor octopus
not really
but it has tentacles and with many arms
i'm sure the guy is good at reaching
just like i'm doing now
now like the comics the syndicate
completely kicked the crap out of
invincible in titan
leaving the ladder at death's door the
guardians arrive and battle beast still
easily beats them and then leaves
realizing that they're no challenge and
it's pointless even wasting the energy
however where things change up is that
we see omniman looking over this
and though he could step in he allows it
to play out with this event coming much
earlier than it did in the comics
they've reordered it to show nolan is
willing to see his son suffer
in order to prove a point further
showcasing how bad he can be
the action is once more awesome and
there's some super gory moments
including black samson
getting absolutely pummeled by battle
beast
monster girl is also left with her skull
on display and this causes robot to
quote unquote break character
and display emotion now this changes up
things a bit from the comics
as it wasn't monster girl and instead it
was bulletproof who ended up getting his
head smashed in
however i think they did this to tease
us something else was going on with
robot
and also showed how much he cared about
monster girl he fires a full blast out
of what i want to call his arc reactor
and the guardians go super saiyan easily
defeating the majority of the syndicate
by working together as a team
rather than as separate individuals
black samson and monster girl do
survive but it's clear that robot is
going to be pushed into helping her in
order to bring her back from the brink
now with mark being badly injured he's
unable to help amber
and earlier in the episode he did ask
for one last chance
i can see him having some splaining to
do next episode
as he likely won't recover from this
anytime soon and will probably have to
finally decide
whether to divulge to amber about his
extracurricular activities
or just keep them a secret at machine
head's office
cecil and the gda cleanup team arrives
and he removes the quantum probability
chip
at the end of the entry we discover that
the gda are actually studying mark's
blood
which they take at this scene in order
to find out a weakness for the
viltromites
neither of these moments are in the
comics i feel that the former is done so
that steadman can work out the best
strategy to take omniman down
a catchphrase in comic culture is that
batman can be anyone if he has prep time
and that of course includes superman who
the dark knight has beaten
on several occasions thus i think cecil
will be doing something similar and
working out all possible eventualities
in order to beat him and they will
prepare his kryptonite through studying
mark's blood
like i said this is completely emitted
from the comics and he doesn't discover
the truth about nolan until it's too
late
here the agency feel like they have a
lot more while agency
and i can see debbie possibly helping
them to fight against him
at machine heads office we see that
titan has now taken over the position of
a crime boss
and alongside isotope and his family he
now rules over the city
this is of course similar to the ending
of the final series of luke cage
though the comics came before and there
are moments in it which make him seem
very much like the kingpin
now we will be talking about some
spoilers going ahead involving robot
so if you don't want anything ruined
then i recommend that you turn off now
okay you still yeah well last week we
saw a strange looking humanoid in a tank
that robot bowed to this is actually
robot himself
and his true name is rudolph connors
rudy controls these drones
and in the comics after hearing monster
girls plea he decided to fix his
condition
with help from the maulers he was able
to clone or explode
and then he duplicated his mind into
that body so he could live
somewhat a normal life now robot
eventually ended up reversing monster
girl's condition too
but with the way things are going i
think he could potentially carry out the
cloning process on her as well
she's badly beaten up and that would
make the most sense to me
as he could also fix her condition
through this method
i've done a full breakdown on robot's
mission in the comics if you want to
check it out after this
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode too so make sure
you drop them below
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league on 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below
with your thoughts on the episode the
winners of last month's competition are
on screen right now
save that to you then message me on
twitter heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of robots
full mission
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom
and talked about his true plan so
definitely give it a watch if you have
any questions
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul and i
see you next time
take care peace